les interventions du docteur Jacques
Segal au centre socio-culturel des
Merisiers à Trappes connaissent toujours
un franc succès et traite de sujets très
différents au programme ce jour-là la
santé des femmes de la puberté à la
ménopause la ménopause n'est pas une
maladie c'est un phénomène naturel qui
arrive à toutes les femmes elle se
déclare par l'arrêt des menstruations
les ovaires arrêtent de fabriquer les
hormones de la reproduction les
oestrogènes et la progestérone ce qui
peut entraîner certaines complications
elles peuvent à cette à ce moment
ressentir des troubles tels que qui
peuvent être très désagréables comme des
bouffées de chaleur comme de la
sécheresse vaginale comme des troubles
de l'attention artérielle il y a tout ce
qui se passe aussi de façon plus
souterraine au niveau du métabolisme des
os qui se raréfient la trame osseuse et
moins solide ce qui fait qu'on a ce
qu'on appelle le l'ostéo porose c'est
pas constant une femme sur deux aucun
trouble à la ménopause à l'aide de
schémas et des changes le docteur Segal
apporte des informations précieuses pour
les personnes présentes et l'explique
bien parce que il y a des docteurs qui
nous expliquent pas bien des fois il y a
des choses quand on connaît pas mais là
explique bien
il nous pose des questions on a des
bonnes réponses la ménopause intervient
chez les femmes autour de la
cinquantaine le docteur Jacques Segal
rappelle l'importance d'être suivi par
un médecin c'est une période où il faut
en plus des examens habituels que sont
la mammographie bien entendu les frottis
l'examen gynécologique il faut pendant
les deux ou trois premières années de la
ménopause au moins une fois par an faire
un examen plus approfondie interroger
les femmes sur comment elle se sentent
en sachant que c'est aussi sur le plan
psychologique une période fragile
pour prévenir les risques d'ostéoporose
il faut passer des examens radiologiques
appelés
ostéo densitométrie il est recommandé de
manger davantage de l'étagé de poissons
d'écouter santé du docteur Jacques Segal
se déroule à trappe une fois par mois